Maybe you saw this story in the news earlier this summer. A man's getting mauled by a shark, maybe 100 yards out from a beach near San Diego. He yells for help, yells "shark." A woman swimming near him also yells. And some guys hear it and swim towards the shark attack to rescue him, which they do. He lives. So, you know, happy ending.
也许你今年夏天早些时候在新闻里看到过这个故事。在圣迭戈附近的一个海滩外约100码处，一名男子正遭到鲨鱼袭击。他大声呼救，喊着“有鲨鱼”。在他附近游泳的一名女子也大声呼喊。一些人听到了，便游向鲨鱼袭击的地方去救他，他们成功了。他活了下来，所以，你知道，这有个圆满的结局。
But here's the question. I couldn't stop thinking about this. Who does that? Who hears somebody yell "shark" and swims towards the shark? What kind of person is that?
但问题来了。我无法停止思考这件事。谁会这么做？听到有人喊“有鲨鱼”还会游向鲨鱼？那是什么样的人？
So I work in real estate development for a company that's based out of LA and Brentwood. We build apartments, hotels, resorts, offices.
我在一家总部位于洛杉矶和布伦特伍德的房地产开发公司工作。我们建造公寓、酒店、度假村和办公室。
Meet Cameron Whiting, 31, single, newly moved to San Diego. And he was there the morning of the shark attack with a group, the North County Ocean Swimmers, that meets four times a week to swim a mile, mile and a half, or more.
这就是卡梅隆·怀廷，31岁，单身，刚搬到圣迭戈。鲨鱼袭击那天早上，他就在那里，和“北县海洋游泳者”小组的一群人在一起，他们每周聚会四次，游一英里、一英里半或更远。
I was out in the water about 100 yards offshore, just past the breaking waves with another swimmer, Kevin Barrett.
当时我离岸边大约100码，刚过碎浪区，和另一名游泳者凯文·巴雷特在一起。
And you guys, had you finished your swim for the day?
那么你们，那天已经游完泳了吗？
Yep. We were done with our swim. Most of the group had made their way in. Some were in the shower. Some were kind of playing in the waves. Kevin and I were body surfing beyond the break, and that's when we heard the screaming.
是的，我们游完了。大多数人都已经上岸了，有些人去冲淋了，有些人还在浪里玩。凯文和我在碎浪区外进行身体冲浪，就在那时我们听到了尖叫声。
How far was it from you?
离你们有多远？
He was probably 50 to 75 yards from us, so just barely within shouting reach. It was hard for us to hear the screams, but the tone of it was so extreme that we knew something really bad was happening.
他离我们大概50到75码，正好在呼喊声能听见的范围内。我们很难听清尖叫的内容，但那种语调极其强烈，我们知道肯定发生了非常糟糕的事情。
So this is the moment I wanted to ask you about. Somebody yells "shark," and then you swim towards the shark. Could you just talk about that moment?
这就是我想问你的时刻。有人喊“有鲨鱼”，然后你就游向了鲨鱼。你能谈谈那一刻吗？
Yeah, that's one of the moments that, in the four weeks since this has happened, that I just keep replaying. And in the moment, everything happens really quickly, and you don't really have a lot of time to psychoanalyze what's going on and what you're feeling. You just kind of react on instinct. But there are a few options in the moment. And I think, in the second it happened, first of all, Kevin Barrett, who was next to me, he just took off.
是的，那是自这件事发生后的四周以来，我一直在脑海中反复回放的时刻之一。那一刻发生得非常快，你没有太多时间去分析到底发生了什么，以及你有什么感觉。你只是凭本能做出反应。但在那一刻有几个选项。我认为，在事情发生的瞬间，首先，在我身边的凯文·巴雷特，他直接冲了过去。
Took off towards the shark, didn't hesitate. But Cameron did hesitate, because Cameron is not only a real estate guy, Cameron is actually this incredible swimmer, the fastest swimmer in this group of ocean swimmers, and also a trained lifeguard who still works as a part-time lifeguard in Los Angeles, where they put you through this rigorous boot camp training, 200 hours over 10 weekends, Lifeguard Academy, including all kinds of ocean rescues.
他冲向了鲨鱼，没有任何犹豫。但卡梅隆犹豫了，因为卡梅隆不仅是个房地产从业者，他还是个游泳高手，是这群海洋游泳者中游得最快的人，也是一名受过训练的救生员，至今仍在洛杉矶兼职做救生员。在那里，他们要经过极其严格的新兵训练，在10个周末里进行200小时的救生学院培训，包括各种海上救援。
They taught us in academy that slow is pro.
学院里教导我们说，慢即是专。
Slow is pro. Professionals stop and assess.
慢即是专。专业人士会停下来评估。
So yeah, there was that split second. But my head was just racing with all the scenarios, and it was, one, we need to make sure somebody is going to get backup.
所以，确实有那么一刹那的停顿。但我的脑海里飞速闪过各种情景，第一点是，我们需要确保有人去寻求支援。
Backup. He looks to the beach to see if anybody's running to call a medic. Looks like yes. On to scenario two, which he was thinking about because he was actually in the middle of getting recertified as a lifeguard.
支援。他看向海滩，看是否有人在跑去叫医护人员。看起来是的。接着是第二个场景，他之所以会想到这个，是因为他当时正好在进行救生员的重新认证。
So it's funny. You have to watch all these videos, and the video I had just watched the night before was how, as a first responder, you can't swim into-- or you shouldn't respond to an unsafe scene. Scene safety is number one.
所以很有趣。你必须观看所有这些视频，而我前一天晚上刚看的视频讲的是，作为第一响应者，你不能游进——或者说你不应该响应一个不安全的现场。现场安全是第一位的。
And in fact, through our lifeguard training, they even taught us in the academy manual that if there's a shark attack, you're not supposed to swim into it. You're supposed to call your supervisor and wait for help. But that just didn't make sense to me in the moment. I think the more important thing they taught us is that you have to make a judgment call in those difficult circumstances.
事实上，在我们的救生员培训中，学院手册甚至教导我们，如果发生鲨鱼袭击，你不应该游进去。你应该通知主管并等待救援。但在那一刻，这对我来说行不通。我认为他们教给我的更重要的一点是，你必须在那些困难的情况下做出判断。
What's so weird about that is that they're saying, like, use your judgment about whether to go in, but what does that even mean in this situation? Like, what data could you be using to make a judgment?
最奇怪的是，他们说，要利用你的判断力决定是否进入，但在这种情况下，那到底意味着什么呢？比如，你到底能利用什么数据来做出判断？
Yeah, for me, it was just years of experience swimming out there, and I felt comfortable. I've swum thousands of miles out there in way sharkier waters, and I've never seen or had an issue with a shark.
是的，对我来说，那只是多年在海上游泳的经验，我感到很自在。我在那片海域游过几千英里，那里的鲨鱼更多，我从未见过鲨鱼或遇到过问题。
And so, even though there was a shark attack, I've heard that when there are shark attacks, usually they bite you, and they kind of spit you out after they realize you aren't what they wanted to eat. And so in my head, I think-- and again, I didn't have a ton of time to analyze this in the moment. But I think the risk of a shark coming back and trying to attack all of us was minimal.
所以，尽管发生了鲨鱼袭击，但我听说过，当鲨鱼袭击时，它们通常咬一口，意识到你不是它们想吃的食物后，就会把你吐出来。所以在我的脑海里，我想——再次声明，我当时没有太多时间去分析这一点——但我觉得鲨鱼回来并试图攻击我们所有人的风险是很小的。
Wow, that's so interesting. I think you see that differently than most of us civilians do. I mean, I think the thing that I've heard, and I feel like so many people have heard, is if there's blood in the water, the sharks are going to stick around because there's blood in the water, you know?
哇，那太有趣了。我想你和我们大多数平民的看法不同。我的意思是，我想我听到过的，也是很多人都听到过的，就是如果有血水，鲨鱼会徘徊不走，因为水里有血，你知道吗？
Totally, yep. I think it was, the shark made a mistake and realized it and probably swam away. And I think the conditions make a big impact, too. I think the morning of the incident, there was red tide, which is a red plankton that makes the water really murky and muddy. It was kind of choppy.
完全同意。我认为是这样，鲨鱼犯了个错误，意识到后可能就游走了。而且我认为条件也有很大影响。我想事发那天早上，有赤潮，这是一种红色的浮游生物，会让水变得非常浑浊和泥泞。当时海浪有点大。
And so in my mind, the shark attack happened because the shark probably couldn't see, and it couldn't tell what it was biting. And it attacked thinking it was a seal, because there was a seal out there that morning.
所以在我看来，鲨鱼袭击是因为它可能看不见，无法辨别它在咬什么。它以为咬的是海豹，因为那天早上确实有一只海豹在那里。
All that said, he was still scared. He says sharks are always in the back of his head as an ocean swimmer. And for whatever random reason, for a couple of months before this day, he'd been having nightmares about sharks coming at him, emerging from the deep. Now he might be heading towards what he calls a 1,500-pound pitbull, agitated and fighting.
尽管如此，他当时还是害怕的。他说作为一名海洋游泳者，他脑子里总是在担心鲨鱼。不知出于什么偶然原因，在那天之前的几个月里，他一直做噩梦，梦见鲨鱼向他袭来，从深渊中浮现。现在他可能正朝着他所说的“1500磅重的斗牛犬”游去，那头鲨鱼正焦躁不安并进行攻击。
But in that quick moment or two before he took action, he took note of a couple of other things. He and Kevin were the closest to the guy who got bit, who was another swimmer from the group. No lifeguards were near.
但在他采取行动前的那一两秒钟里，他注意到了其他几件事。他和凯文离那个被咬的人最近，那人也是小组里的另一名游泳者。附近没有救生员。
And I think I just did the math in my head in that split second of, I think the thought of living for the rest of my life, knowing that I was in a position to help and not doing it, would have just eaten away at me way more than the thought of swimming into something that's dangerous.
我想我当时那一瞬间在心里做了计算，我想，如果余生都知道自己有能力帮忙却没去帮，这会比游向危险更让我备受煎熬。
That's funny when you weigh it up like this. I feel like the math of it actually seems really, really clear. You're like, I'm a really good swimmer. I'm trained for this. Other people are further away. And I really don't think the shark's going to bite me. Like, the math is so straightforward.
当你这样权衡时，真是很有意思。我觉得这背后的逻辑其实非常非常清晰。你心想，我是个游泳好手，我受过这种训练。其他人都在更远的地方。而且我真的不认为鲨鱼会咬我。这逻辑太直白了。
Yeah, in my mind, it didn't seem like a huge thing. I was just out there in the right place, in the right time. But again, Kevin's the one that really made that first move and inspired the courage in me to go.
是的，在我心里，这看起来并不是什么了不起的事。我只是正好在那个时间出现在了那个地点。但话说回来，凯文才是那个真正采取行动并激发我勇气的人。
And had Kevin done this kind of training, too?
凯文也接受过这种训练吗？
He hadn't. And he jokes that the reason he instantly responded the way he did out of instinct was because he didn't have the training. [LAUGHS]
他没有。他开玩笑说，他之所以能凭借本能立即做出反应，就是因为他没有接受过那种训练。（笑）
I didn't think. I really didn't. I just reacted.
我没多想。真的没有。我只是做出了反应。
This, of course, is Kevin Barrett, 51 years old the day he hurled his body through the water towards a shark attack-- married, two teenage sons. Pays the bills as a financial advisor, but also has a little startup trying to convert ocean waves and their motion into electricity.
这当然就是凯文·巴雷特，那天他奋不顾身地冲向鲨鱼袭击现场时51岁，已婚，有两个十几岁的儿子。他做财务顾问赚钱，但也有一个小小的初创公司，试图将海浪及其运动转化为电能。
He used to play rugby and do triathlons, but at some point switched to ocean swimming. And talking with him about why a person might swim towards a shark attack is pretty much the opposite day, upside down world, mirror universe, black-is-white version of talking with Cameron about it.
他过去常打橄榄球和参加铁人三项，但在某个时刻转向了海洋游泳。和他谈论为什么一个人会游向鲨鱼袭击现场，这与和卡梅隆谈论这件事几乎是完全相反的世界，颠倒的世界，镜像宇宙，黑白颠倒。
It's almost, ignorance is bliss, right? I didn't have that knowledge set. And so for me, it was, my friend's in trouble. I just reacted and went to him. Right? I didn't have the same knowledge that Cameron had. So I just reacted.
几乎是无知者无畏，对吧？我没有那套知识体系。所以对我来说，就是我的朋友有危险了。我只是做出了反应，就向他游去了。对吧？我没有卡梅隆那样的知识。所以我只是做出了反应。
Well, it's funny. When he describes his thing, it's almost not heroic. He just did the math. You know what I mean? Like, whereas when you describe yours, it's way more heroic because you're just sort of throwing yourself at danger. Did you assume that the shark would probably swim away once it bit him that one time?
嗯，真有趣。当他描述他的行为时，简直称不上英勇。他只是做了那个决定，你知道我的意思吗？而当你描述你的行为时，因为你只是把自己投向危险，这显得更加英勇。你当时是否认为鲨鱼咬了一口之后可能会游走？
Honestly, I didn't. I really didn't think too much about the shark. I was really just focused on Caleb.
老实说，并没有。我真的没太考虑鲨鱼。我当时满脑子想的只是凯勒布。
Caleb, the guy who got bit.
凯勒布，那个被咬的人。
I was like, I need to get my friend, you know? He's injured. And how bad are his injuries? And let's get him to shore.
我当时心想，我得救我的朋友，你知道吗？他受伤了。他的伤势有多严重？让我们带他上岸。
Hmm. How well do you know Caleb?
嗯。你和凯勒布认识多久了？
I'd only met-- this was the third time I'd met him.
我只见过他——这是我第三次见到他。
The third time he'd met him. They'd chatted a little about rugby on the beach. Caleb also used to play. That is the extent of the friendship for which he risked his life. People, man.
这是他第三次见到他。他们在海滩上聊过一会儿关于橄榄球的话题。凯勒布过去也打过橄榄球。这就是他为此冒着生命危险的友情的全部。人们啊，真是的。
Kevin and Cameron would both be very annoyed with me if I did not point out right now that other people were also critical to saving Caleb's life that day. There was the woman who stayed by him during the attack and yelled for help.
如果我现在不指出那天还有其他人对拯救凯勒布的生命至关重要，凯文和卡梅隆都会对我感到非常恼火。当时还有一位女士在袭击期间一直待在他身边并大声呼救。
Then, when they got to Caleb, he was bleeding badly, like a lawn mower hit his torso, Cameron said. The shark was gone, and a surfer approached with a surfboard. They put Caleb on, get him to shore. Then there were medics, of course, and others who helped. Caleb is fine now.
当他们到达凯勒布身边时，他流血严重，卡梅隆说就像割草机撞到了他的躯干。鲨鱼已经走了，一名冲浪者带着冲浪板游了过来。他们把凯勒布抬上去，带他上岸。当然，还有医护人员和其他提供帮助的人。凯勒布现在很好。
Cameron and Kevin both said that since this story hit the news, lots of people have come up to them, saying they could never have done what the two of them did. They would not have swum toward a shark. Cameron says he tells them, you'd be surprised at what you can do. Kevin tells them, of course you would.
卡梅隆和凯文都说，自从这个故事登上新闻后，很多人走到他们面前说，他们绝对做不到他们俩做过的事。他们绝不会游向鲨鱼。卡梅隆说他告诉他们，你会惊讶于自己能做到什么。凯文告诉他们，你当然会。
People, I think, are innately good. And we will do the right thing when pressed, right? And I'm just like you. And hey, we do good.
我认为人本性是善良的。当我们受到压力时，我们会做出正确的事情，对吧？我只是和你一样的人。嘿，我们要做好事。
I don't know. I think you and I see people differently. I think that we are a mix of good and bad. And all the people who say, like, I wouldn't do that, I think that those people, many of them are telling the truth.
我不知道。我觉得你看待人的方式和我不同。我认为我们是好与坏的混合体。对于那些说“我不会那么做”的人，我觉得其中很多人说的是实话。
And I guess that's where we differ. I'm not any different to anybody else. And this is the reaction that I had. Trust that you would have the similar reaction. That's a cool thing to think about.
我想这就是我们的分歧所在。我并不比任何人特别。这就是我做出的反应。要相信你也会有类似的反应。这想法挺酷的。
That is a cool thing to think about. And we don't agree on this. I do think that there are some people who are like you and some people who aren't. But because this is your interview and not mine, you will get the last word.
那确实是个很酷的想法。我们在这一点上没有达成共识。我确实认为有些人像你，有些人则不然。但因为这是你的访谈而不是我的，所以你会拥有最后发言权。
[LAUGHS] OK. Good.
（笑）好的。太好了。
Today on our show, people who decide to put themselves in danger and swim towards sharks. Sometimes, they're doing it out of idealism, for the greater good of everybody, because they're good people-- if such a thing exists.
今天在我们的节目中，讲述的是那些决定让自己身陷险境并游向鲨鱼的人。有时，他们这样做是出于理想主义，为了所有人的更大福祉，因为他们是好人——如果世上真有这种人存在的话。
Sometimes, it's purely personal and the only way they know to fix some problem in their own life. Sometimes, the people around them do not understand why they're doing it at all. True stories of human peril and the people who seek it out. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
有时，这是纯粹个人的，是他们修复自己生活中某种问题的唯一途径。有时，周围的人根本不理解他们为什么要这样做。这是关于人类困境及其寻求者们的真实故事。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
It's This American Life. Act One, "If I Only Had My Brain." When Sarah was 15, she landed the lead role with a professional theater company playing Alice, the lead role in Alice Through the Looking Glass. And during the course of the production, she became petrified of going on stage, stage fright at an almost chemical level.
这是《美国生活》。第一幕，“如果我有大脑”。莎拉15岁时，在一家专业剧团担任主演，饰演《爱丽丝镜中奇遇记》中的爱丽丝。在制作过程中，她变得对登台表演感到极度恐惧，这种舞台恐惧症达到了近乎生理反应的程度。
Every day, she says, the very thought of doing the show again drenched her in sweat. Her heart pounded so hard, she thought it might explode. She was afraid. And she was afraid people would discover she was afraid, which made it worse.
她说，每天一想到要再次演出，她就汗如雨下。她的心脏剧烈跳动，她以为心脏可能会爆炸。她害怕。她还害怕别人会发现她很害怕，这让情况变得更糟。
And long story, but she lied her way out of the gig so she didn't have to do it anymore, which ended the play's run early, leaving her adult cast members who needed work out of work. She felt really bad about that, didn't own up to it for years after.
故事很长，但她撒谎退出了演出，这样她就不必再表演了。这导致该剧提前结束，让需要工作的成年演员失业了。她对此感到非常难过，多年后才敢承认。
The funny thing is, Sarah, she'd acted a bunch before this-- and after it, in movies, on TV, where there's no audience with you in the room. You may have heard of her, Sarah Polley. These days, she works behind the camera as a director and a screenwriter. But being on stage, after that one production, it was a shark she did not swim toward, one of several.
有趣的是，在这之前和之后，莎拉在电影和电视中演过很多戏，那些地方没有观众和你在一起。你可能听说过她，莎拉·波莉。如今，她在幕后担任导演和编剧。但在那次制作之后，登台表演成了她没有游向的一条鲨鱼，她是几条鲨鱼中的一条。
Yes, I've never been somebody to push myself. In general, if something makes me anxious, I don't do it. And certainly, throughout my acting career, there are a lot of things I just backed right away from the second they started to make me anxious at all. Like, I just didn't want the trouble. It's time to move in a different direction.
是的，我从来不是一个会逼迫自己的人。通常情况下，如果某件事让我焦虑，我就不做。当然，在我的演艺生涯中，很多事情我一感到焦虑就马上退缩了。比如，我只是不想惹麻烦。是时候往另一个方向发展了。
And then, a couple of decades later, well into adulthood, something happened that just changed all of that, made her way less avoidant, fearful. And it wasn't a thing that you would expect. She told the story to one of our producers, Sean Cole.
然后，几十年后，步入成年，发生了一件事彻底改变了这一切，让她变得不再那么逃避、恐惧。这并不是你预料之中的那种事。她把这个故事告诉了我们的制片人之一，肖恩·科尔。
So it's October 2015. Sarah had just finished swimming, actually, at the local rec center and was getting ready to walk home, but her hair's wet and it's chilly outside. It's Toronto, where she lives. It gets cold. And she can't find her blow-dryer. Goes to the front desk, says, has anybody seen it? The woman says, meh, go check the lost and found bin.
那是2015年10月。莎拉刚刚在当地的娱乐中心游完泳，正准备走回家，但她的头发是湿的，外面很冷。这是在多伦多，她居住的地方，天气很冷。她找不到吹风机了。她走到前台问，有人看见它吗？那个女人说，嗯，去看看失物招领箱吧。
So she goes over to the corner of the lobby and crouches down to rummage around in the bin, above which, hanging on the wall, is this big industrial fire extinguisher.
于是她走到大厅的角落，蹲下来在箱子里翻找，箱子上方墙上挂着一个巨大的工业灭火器。
I was overheating, and I stood up quickly to toss my winter coat off in a kind of tantrum. And I think what must have happened is my shoulder must have dislodged the fire extinguisher, and it crashed down on the left side of my head. So my memory after that is foggy.
我当时热得不行，快速站起来，想要发泄似地甩掉冬大衣。我想一定是我的肩膀碰到并移位了灭火器，它砸到了我的左侧头部。之后的记忆就很模糊了。
But what I do remember is, I felt like all my teeth were going to fall out of my head. I had a lot of thoughts about dentistry and how I wished I knew more about dentistry, because that seemed like a priority at that moment. And I kind of put together very slowly this terrible pain in my teeth and on the left side of my jaw and head with the fact there was this huge clang around the same time, and I could see the fire extinguisher rolling. And I realized I should probably let someone know.
但我记得的是，我觉得所有的牙齿都要掉出来了。我想了很多关于牙科的事情，真希望自己能多懂点牙科知识，因为那在当时看来是重中之重。我慢慢地把牙齿和左颚及头部的剧痛，与灭火器掉落时发出的巨响联系在一起。我看到灭火器在滚动。我意识到我可能应该让别人知道。
And so I started saying, in a very monotone voice, to no one in particular, a fire extinguisher just fell on my head. A fire extinguisher just fell on my head. And it was literally like listening to a robot. There was no affect in the voice that I heard coming out of me.
于是我开始用一种非常单调的声音，对着空气说，一个灭火器刚砸到了我的头上。一个灭火器刚砸到了我的头上。那听起来简直就像在听一个机器人说话。我听到的自己的声音里没有任何情感。
The woman behind the counter ran to get help, but instead of waiting around, Sarah just set off on her walk home, which wasn't easy. Somehow, her body kept veering to the right, onto people's lawns.
柜台后的女人跑去寻求帮助，但莎拉没有等，而是动身回家，这并不容易。不知何故，她的身体一直向右倾斜，走到别人的草坪上去了。
I felt like I was underwater. I felt like everything was way too loud. But I also felt like, I have two tiny kids. I'm in the middle of a job. Nothing can have happened to me right now because that's just not possible. I just can't make room for that at the moment, so.
我觉得自己好像在水下。我觉得周围一切都太吵了。但我也觉得，我有两个小孩子。我正在工作中。不可能发生什么事情在我身上，因为那是不可能的。我现在实在无法接受那种可能，所以。
You might have guessed by now that she'd suffered a concussion, in which case you know more about Sarah's brain than she did in those first few hours after the accident. For her, it was one of those moments where you're not sure yet how serious or benign an injury might turn out to be. And if you just act casual, maybe it'll get better on its own.
你现在可能已经猜到了她受了脑震荡，如果是这样，那你比她事故后最初的几个小时里对自己大脑的了解要多得多。对她来说，那是那种你还不确定伤势会变得多么严重或良性的时刻。如果你只是装作若无其事，也许它会自行好转。
But in the kitchen that night, making dinner, both her kids bouncing around, she started to experience her brain like a new appliance she wasn't used to yet and was kind of in awe of.
但那天晚上在厨房做饭时，两个孩子蹦蹦跳跳，她开始体验到自己的大脑就像一个她还不习惯使用的新设备，让她感到敬畏。
Everything for me became scrambled. So I remember having the thought, how am I supposed to open the oven and turn it on if they're making so much noise?
对我来说，一切都变得混乱了。我记得当时想，如果他们发出这么大的噪音，我该怎么打开烤箱并启动它呢？
Wow.
哇。
And I remember going, well, that's an odd thought, but I couldn't quite piece together why it was an odd thought. And I think the moment I really had to admit something was wrong was-- even though something was obviously wrong-- was I snapped at my three-year-old in a way that I just had never snapped before.
我记得自己心想，那是个奇怪的想法，但我无法完全理清为什么那是个奇怪的想法。我认为我真正不得不承认自己出了问题的那一刻是——尽管很明显出了问题——我对我三岁的孩子发了火，那种发火方式我以前从未有过。
And I remember holding these little shoulders and these eyes looking up at me, shocked. And then I became shocked because I was like, what am I doing? I mean, I wasn't rough, but it was way beyond how I had ever been.
我记得抓着那小小的肩膀，看着那双注视我的眼睛，感到震惊。然后我变得震惊，因为我想，我在做什么？我的意思是，我并不粗鲁，但这远远超过了我以前的程度。
And I remember just backing up and removing myself and going and sitting in a dark room and going, something's happened. I feel like I can cut through the air with my hand like it's butter, like it's a substance. And I remember saying to my husband, David, did reality always feel like this?
我记得只是退后，离开那里，坐进一个黑暗的房间，心想，发生了什么事。我觉得我可以像切黄油一样切开空气，好像它是一种实质性的东西。我记得我对丈夫大卫说，现实一直都是这种感觉吗？
You know when they say the answer is located within the question? This was one of those times.
你知道人们常说答案就在问题中吗？这就是那种时刻之一。
Sarah called her sister, who's a doctor, and who said, yeah, it's a concussion. All the classic symptoms-- oversensitivity to noise and light, confusion, wooziness. She told Sarah to just take it easy. Probably, she'd be back to normal in no time. But that's not what happened. Sarah had all of those symptoms, plus fatigue, occasional nausea, and terrible migraines on and off for the next 3 and 1/2 years.
莎拉给做医生的姐姐打了电话，对方说，是的，是脑震荡。所有典型的症状——对噪音和光线过敏、困惑、眩晕。她告诉莎拉只需要静养。大概很快就能恢复正常。但事实并非如此。莎拉有所有这些症状，加上疲劳、偶尔恶心，以及在接下来的3年半里断断续续的剧烈偏头痛。
Some days, she'd just lay in a dark room for hours because the headaches were too much. The light sensitivity also meant limiting her screen time, so she could barely work. She was actually in the middle of adapting the novel Little Women into a screenplay when she got hit on the head, that gig that ultimately went to Greta Gerwig instead. Also very challenging-- just hanging out with friends and family.
有些日子，她只是在黑暗的房间里躺上几个小时，因为头痛得太厉害。对光敏感也意味着限制使用屏幕的时间，所以她几乎无法工作。当她头部被砸时，她实际上正在改编小说《小妇人》的剧本，那份工作最终落到了格蕾塔·葛韦格手里。这非常具有挑战性——即使只是和朋友家人待在一起也是如此。
Like in a conversation at dinner, where there's things going on, I haven't been able to follow what people are saying. And I was really good at faking it, but half the time, I didn't know what the hell was going on. And it was scary and embarrassing.
就像晚餐时的谈话，周围有很多事发生时，我无法跟上人们在说什么。我非常擅长伪装，但有一半的时间，我根本不知道到底发生了什么。这很可怕，也很尴尬。
But the biggest heartbreak was not being able to care for her kids that much, especially in the first year. Couldn't take them to school, couldn't go to their events. She just became less and less involved with their lives. And this is the story of how she made her way out of that hole, taking a path that was totally unexpected.
但最大的心碎是无法过多照顾自己的孩子，尤其是在第一年。无法送他们上学，无法参加他们的活动。她参与他们生活的程度越来越低。这就是她如何走出那个深渊的故事，走上了一条完全出乎意料的道路。
At first, she was just marching herself around to doctor after doctor. She actually published an essay in a book of essays about all of this. This part's a good summation of the different treatments she tried, so I asked her to read it.
起初，她只是把自己带去见一位又一位医生。她实际上在一部论文集中发表了一篇关于所有这些经历的文章。这一部分总结了她尝试过的不同治疗方法，所以我请她读一读。
"I go to a neurofeedback specialist who tells me, after I spent an exhausting day watching balls bounce around on a computer screen, that I am in the one percentile for attention span for my age and gender. This will haunt me for years. A nutritionist who tells me to stop eating gluten and dairy and a chiropractor who apparently helped cure hockey player Sidney Crosby."
“我去了一位神经反馈专家那里，他在我花费了令人精疲力竭的一天观看球体在电脑屏幕上弹跳后告诉我，我的注意力集中时间在我的年龄和性别中处于倒数第一位。这将困扰我多年。还有一位营养师告诉我停止吃麸质和乳制品，以及一位据说治愈了冰球运动员西德尼·克罗斯比的脊椎按摩师。”
Sidney Crosby is a hockey legend, just to say. In 2011, he was diagnosed with a concussion that famously benched him for about a year.
西德尼·克罗斯比是冰球传奇人物，顺便提一下。2011年，他被诊断出患有脑震荡，这让他被迫休战了大约一年，这件事很有名。
"I will later realize that almost everyone out there specializing in concussions has a rumor swirling around them that they cured Sidney Crosby. After a while, whenever anyone starts to rave about a concussion miracle worker they know, I say, let me guess-- he treated Sidney Crosby. The answer is invariably yes."
“后来我意识到，几乎所有专注于脑震荡的人身上都流传着一种谣言，说他们治愈了西德尼·克罗斯比。一段时间后，每当有人开始热烈地谈论他们认识的脑震荡神医时，我会说，让我猜猜——他治疗过西德尼·克罗斯比。答案总是肯定的。”
Out of the tangle of advice, much of it conflicting, stuck this one common thread, that Sarah should do as much as she felt like she could handle, but when she reached the point where she couldn't tolerate the stimulation or the sunlight or traffic sounds or whatever it was, then back off. Don't try to push yourself past the point where your body is telling you to quit, and make sure to get lots of rest.
在混乱的建议中，很多都是相互矛盾的，但有一条共同点：莎拉应该尽可能多地做她觉得能应付的事情，但当她达到无法忍受刺激、阳光或交通噪音等任何东西的临界点时，就退回来。不要试图强迫自己超过身体告诉你放弃的极限，并确保获得充分的休息。
It's not exactly rare, this condition. It's been referred to as post-concussion syndrome. Maybe 15% or 20% of people with concussions develop some form of it. In fact, Sarah's friend Meredith happened to be dealing with it at the same time. They'd compare notes. Meredith always wore wraparound shades and wide-brimmed hats when she went outside.
这种情况并不罕见。它被称为脑震荡后综合征。也许15%或20%的脑震荡患者会产生某种形式的症状。事实上，莎拉的朋友梅雷迪斯正好在同一时间处理这种情况。她们会比较记录。梅雷迪斯出门时总是戴着遮阳眼镜和宽檐帽。
And somewhere around year 3, Sarah got almost used to her limitations. She kept detailed notes about her symptoms-- when they showed up, how severe they were. And in what she calls an irrational fit of optimism, she and David decide to have a third kid, which would have been a huge load for anyone. But for Sarah, it was insurmountable. She felt just as bad as she did on day one and starts to give up on ever being recognizably herself again.
在大约第3年，莎拉几乎习惯了她的局限。她记录了关于自己症状的详细记录——它们何时出现，严重程度如何。怀着一种她自己称之为非理性的乐观，她和大卫决定生第三个孩子，这对任何人来说都是巨大的负担。但对莎拉来说，这是无法逾越的。她感觉和第一天一样糟糕，并开始放弃恢复原本自己的希望。
And then, one day, 3 and 1/2 years in, Sarah sees Meredith, her concussion buddy, on the street, except now, out of nowhere, Meredith's fine. No wraparound shades, no wide-brimmed hat. She basically says she was cured by this doctor in Pittsburgh, Dr. Michael Collins.
然后有一天，在第3年半，莎拉在街上看到了她的脑震荡伙伴梅雷迪斯，除了现在，不知从哪里冒出来的，梅雷迪斯好了。没有遮阳眼镜，没有宽檐帽。她基本上说她是匹兹堡的一位医生，迈克尔·柯林斯医生治愈的。
And the more Sarah learned about him, the more snake oily the whole thing sounded. There's just so much debate around the science of concussions, and the cure seems so elusive. And now, here is this guy who was completely confident that he could fix what was wrong, that there was a method to it. Plus, the way his patients felt about him seemed cultish and weird.
莎拉对他了解得越多，整件事听起来就越像江湖骗子。关于脑震荡的科学争论太多了，治疗方法似乎难以捉摸。而现在，这个家伙却完全自信他能解决她的问题，说有一套方法。此外，他的病人们对他那种崇拜式的态度显得很奇怪。
And besides being skeptical, Sarah, who, remember, is Canadian and explicitly asked me to include this, she didn't want to buy into the notion that health care in the US is superior to what you could get in Canada-- and literally buy in. She's like, nobody should have to pay for health care. It made her feel gross.
除了持怀疑态度，莎拉——记得她是加拿大人，特意要求我包括这一点——不想认同美国的医疗保健优于加拿大这一观点——并且确实在购买它。她觉得，没有人应该为医疗保健买单。这让她感到恶心。
But all of that said, she had tried everything else. Maybe a little snake oil was what she needed. So she booked an appointment and brought her friend, Kate, down with her to Pittsburgh to sit with her and take notes on what the doctor said so she'd remember. The trip itself was hugely taxing for her. And when the time came to see Dr. Collins, he was not what she expected.
但话虽如此，她尝试了所有其他办法。也许一点江湖骗术正是她所需要的。于是她预约了医生，带上她的朋友凯特一起去了匹兹堡，坐在旁边记录医生说的话，以便她能记住。这趟旅行本身对她来说就极其吃力。当见到柯林斯医生时，他并不是她预想的那样。
He kind of burst into the room in whatever a Canadian stereotypical image of an American is. It was like America came into the room. He was really direct, didn't hold back. He was loud. He didn't have a lot of time for niceties. I literally felt like Kate and I were like, our hair is being blown back by the sheer energy of this man.
他简直是冲进了房间，带着任何加拿大人对美国人的典型印象。就像美国直接走进了房间。他非常直接，毫不保留。他嗓门大。他没有太多时间去客套。我真的觉得凯特和我，我们的头发都被这个男人的纯粹能量吹到了后面。
He immediately points at Kate, who's quietly taking notes in the corner.
他立刻指着躲在角落里安静记笔记的凯特。
That's not going to help. I read all your husband's notes. He's taking all these notes about your symptoms. That's not going to help. And he yelled at Kate, and he was like, put that pen down. You're not helping. And Kate dropped her pen and was like--
那没用。我读了所有你丈夫的笔记。他在记所有关于你症状的笔记。那没用。他冲凯特喊道，就像，把那支笔放下。你帮不上忙。凯特放下笔，就像——
And he's talking at that volume of voice? Like--
他是用那个音量说话的吗？比如——
Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, he's a really intense guy. And I mean, I was used to a lot of "listen to your body," "be gentle with yourself." And he was like, stop tracking your symptoms. You're not helping yourself by tracking your symptoms, which I was extremely good at.
是的，是的，是的。不，他是个非常强硬的人。我的意思是，我习惯了很多“倾听你的身体”、“对自己温柔一点”之类的建议。而他却说，停止追踪你的症状。通过追踪你的症状，你对自己一点帮助都没有，而我在这方面非常擅长。
And I mean, he's basically like-- I don't know. I don't play sports. It's what I imagine an American football coach is like. The first thing he had said was, we're going to have to pin our ears and go after this thing, which is like my kid's favorite expression. We're going to have to pin our ears and go after this thing.
我的意思是，他基本上就像——我不知道。我不参加体育运动。这是我想象中美式橄榄球教练的样子。他说的第一件事是，我们得咬紧牙关，去对抗这个东西，这正是我孩子最喜欢的表达。我们得咬紧牙关，去对抗这个东西。
He basically told Sarah that she was thinking about her concussion as something she needed to make room for in her life, which was exactly wrong.
他基本上告诉莎拉，她把脑震荡想成了她生活中需要腾出空间来容纳的东西，这完全是错的。
He said, if there's one thing I need you to remember from this meeting, if you don't remember anything else-- and there was a possibility I wouldn't, because Kate wasn't allowed to take notes because he yelled at her. If there's only one thing you remember from this meeting today, it's this-- run towards the danger.
他说，如果有什么事是我需要你从这次会面中记住的，如果你记不住别的什么——而且很有可能我记不住，因为凯特不被允许做笔记，因为他冲她喊了。如果你今天从这次会面中只能记住一件事，那就是这个——冲向危险。
Run towards the danger.
冲向危险。
Anything that's traditionally triggered your symptoms, you're doing more of. So now, if you're watching TV with someone, you have to ask if it's loud enough for them, because they might be keeping it lower for your concussion. You have to ask if the room is bright enough for other people because everyone's probably gotten to a habit of lower light for you and your concussion.
任何传统上触发你症状的事情，你都要做更多。所以现在，如果你和别人一起看电视，你必须问他们音量够不够大，因为他们可能为了你的脑震荡把音量调低了。你必须问房间对其他人来说够不够亮，因为大家可能已经习惯了为你和你的脑震荡调低灯光。
You have to basically just take off all the band-aids. And what I was not allowed to do was-- he was like, if I hear that you're having a nap, ever, I will yell at you. If you have a nap in the day, I will yell at you.
你必须基本上摘掉所有的绷带。我被禁止做的是——他说，如果我听说你睡午觉，哪怕一次，我就冲你喊。如果你白天睡午觉，我就冲你喊。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
And he meant it. And I was like, holy shit. What if I'm trying to make breakfast for my kids, breastfeed my baby, I'm alone at home, I'm trying to get them all off to school? Just thinking about that gives me a migraine. I mean, what if I get a migraine if I'm overextending myself in that way, and then I can't function for the rest of the day? And he just looked at me and yelled, attack, attack, attack!
他是认真的。我当时想，天哪。如果我正在尝试为孩子们做早餐，给婴儿哺乳，我一个人在家，试图让他们都去上学呢？光是想想这些就让我偏头痛。我的意思是，如果我那样过度劳累导致偏头痛，然后余下的一天都无法正常工作怎么办？他只是看着我，喊道，攻击，攻击，攻击！
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
It was so arresting.
这太引人注目了。
Remember, this was, like, the opposite of what every other doctor had told her. Everybody else was like, don't push past the point of your own tolerance. And Dr. Collins was like, push past the point of your own tolerance. Keep going. Sarah asked him how long it would take for her to get better, and he said, hmm, a pretty straightforward case, maybe four to six weeks, which is when she became firmly convinced that he was a charlatan.
记住，这就像是其他每一位医生告诉她的完全相反的事情。其他每个人都说，不要超过你耐受力的极限。而柯林斯医生却说，超过你的耐受极限。继续前进。莎拉问他她需要多久才能好转，他说，嗯，一个相当直截了当的病例，大概四到六周，就在那时，她坚信他是个骗子。
But he's not a charlatan. For all of the ear pinning and attack, attack, attack stuff, Dr. Michael Collins is a world-renowned leading expert in concussions. He's a clinical neuropsychologist, not an MD. But he helped develop a special diagnostic tool to test the severity and type of concussion. Yes, there are different types of concussions-- six of them, in fact.
但他不是骗子。尽管有咬牙、攻击、攻击、攻击那些东西，迈克尔·柯林斯医生是世界公认的脑震荡领先专家。他是临床神经心理学家，不是医学博士。但他参与开发了一种专门的诊断工具来测试脑震荡的严重程度和类型。是的，脑震荡确实有不同的类型——事实上，有六种。
And he's worked on hundreds of research articles and important studies in the field. And the way his team approaches treatment is becoming more and more accepted, both here and in other countries. Oh, and also--
他参与了数百篇研究文章和领域内的重要研究。他的团队处理治疗的方法正变得越来越被认可，无论是在这里还是在其他国家。哦，对了，还有——
We're making progress in Sid's case, and I anticipate Sid returning to hockey and playing well in the future.
我们在西德的情况上取得了进展，我预计西德会回到冰球场，在未来打得很好。
--he actually did treat the hockey player Sidney Crosby. This is from a press conference where Sidney is literally sitting two chairs away from him.
——他确实治疗过冰球运动员西德尼·克罗斯比。这是一场新闻发布会，西德就坐在离他两张椅子的位置。
Yesterday, actually, I assessed Sid. And I can tell you that his data is the best we've seen. It is approaching--
昨天，我实际上评估了西德。我可以告诉你，他的数据是我们见过的最好的。它正在接近——
I got in touch with Michael Collins, or Mickey to people who know him. First and foremost, I asked him what was going on with all the yelling.
我和迈克尔·柯林斯取得了联系，或者说熟悉他的人称他为米奇。首先，我问他那一阵阵的喊叫是怎么回事。
I was having a tough day that day.
那天我过得很艰难。
He said he'd been running hours behind schedule on some really complicated cases before seeing Sarah. But beyond that, he says he felt like he needed to get through to her, literally loud and clear, that noise and stimulation were not the enemy.
他说他在见到莎拉之前，一些非常复杂的病例让他进度落后了几个小时。但除此之外，他说他觉得他需要让她明白，声音和刺激不是敌人，一定要响亮而清晰。
Put very simply, the bash on Sarah's head injured this part of her brain that allows you to interpret motion and busy environments. So the system gets overloaded and can't manage everything that's flying at it. And the injury also caused anxiety.
简单来说，莎拉头部受到的重创伤害了她大脑中允许你解读运动和忙碌环境的那一部分。所以系统过载了，无法处理飞向它的一切。这次伤害也导致了焦虑。
But here's the weird part-- whenever Sarah felt anxiety about, like, going to a social event, that anxiety alone could also trigger her physical concussion symptoms-- the brain fog, wooziness, and confusion. It's a two-way conversation. And so you run toward the danger to interrupt that conversation. You just ignore your anxiety about the symptoms, and so the anxiety and the symptoms both start to fade.
但奇怪的地方在于——每当莎拉感到焦虑时，比如要去参加一个社交活动，仅仅那种焦虑本身就能引发她的身体脑震荡症状——脑雾、头晕和混乱。这是一个双向的对话。所以你冲向危险是为了打断那种对话。你只是忽略了对症状的焦虑，焦虑和症状就开始同时消退了。
She had the type of concussion where it's not rest that gets someone better. It's about rehabituation and retraining. And so to make sure she was aware of that-- because every instinct in your body when you're going through this is to back off things. And so yeah, a part of it was I was having a busy day, but a part of it was she needed to hear it. And she needed to understand that there's only one way out, and that's through it. We actually wanted her to have symptoms. We wanted her to feel it.
她患有的那种脑震荡并不是靠休息就能好的。而是关于重新习惯化和重新训练。所以为了确保她意识到这一点——因为当你经历这些时，身体里的每一个本能都是去逃避事情。所以是的，部分原因是我那天很忙，但部分原因是她需要听到这些。她需要明白只有一条出路，那就是直面它。我们实际上想让她有症状。我们想让她感觉到它。
And just to say, he's not yell-y with every patient. And some patients have completely different kinds of concussions. Please consult a physician before treating your own concussion by going to a Five Finger Death Punch concert.
顺便提一下，他对每个病人都不这样。有些病人有完全不同类型的脑震荡。在通过去参加Five Finger Death Punch演唱会治疗你自己的脑震荡之前，请务必咨询医生。
But with Sarah, he told her, we're going to put you on an intensive retraining program-- exercise, including very specific exercises to get that motion interpretation system-- it's called the vestibular system-- working again, and all the classic exposure therapy you just heard about. Dr. Collins warned her that this would be very uncomfortable at first. He was not lying.
但对于莎拉，他告诉她，我们要让你进行强化重新训练计划——运动，包括非常具体的练习，让那种运动解读系统——即所谓的前庭系统——重新工作，以及你刚才听到的所有经典的暴露疗法。柯林斯医生警告她，起初会非常不舒服。他没撒谎。
I was in agony. Everything hurt. I had worse brain fog at times. It was exhausting. It made me nauseous. It gave me headaches.
我痛苦不堪。一切都疼。有时脑雾更严重。这令人精疲力竭。它让我恶心。它让我头痛。
Take, for example, a simple visit to the grocery store. For years, her husband had been doing most of the shopping, but now, shopping was prescribed.
举个例子，去杂货店买东西。多年来，她丈夫承担了大部分购物，但现在，购物成了处方。
Just the number of things that were happening, like the bright lights, the music, needing to make decisions about what to pull off the shelf, looking at a list, which, again, when you can see how much work each of those steps takes for your brain to process and execute, it is an explosion of exhaustion and pain. And certainly, I remember being at a kids' concert, like a kids' rock concert in the gym.
光是发生的事情的数量，比如明亮的灯光、音乐，需要决定从货架上拿什么，看清单，再次强调，当你能看到大脑处理和执行每一个步骤需要付出多少工作时，那简直是精疲力竭和痛苦的爆发。当然，我记得在一个儿童音乐会上，比如在体育馆里举办的儿童摇滚音乐会。
A thing that I think that even people without hypersensitivity to loud noises do not necessarily enjoy.
我想即使是对噪音没有过度敏感的人也不一定喜欢这种活动。
And I just wanted to die. And it was like, it must have been such a sight because you position your face in a certain kind of way at a kids' performance, which I was incapable of doing.
我当时简直想死。那场面一定很滑稽，因为你在儿童表演时会以某种方式控制自己的面部表情，而我完全做不到。
Yeah, my brain was exploding a lot in those first few weeks. And then there was this moment where we'd been invited out.
是的，在最初的几周里，我的大脑经常爆炸。然后有那么一个时刻，我们被邀请出去了。
This is maybe two or three weeks into the treatment.
这大概是在治疗两三周后。
David had this new colleague and his partner, and we went to a restaurant, and I was bringing my breastfeeding baby into a restaurant while having to socialize with new people, with noise and light. And I said yes because I had to, because it was part of my program to say yes to these things. And I realized halfway through the conversation that I had been following the whole conversation--
大卫有了个新同事和他的伴侣，我们去了一家餐馆，我必须一边给哺乳期的婴儿喂奶，一边与新朋友社交，还要应对噪音和光线。我答应了，因为我必须答应，因为向这些事情说“是”是我的计划的一部分。谈话进行到一半，我意识到我一直在跟上整个谈话——
Hmm!
嗯！
--and that I wasn't lost, and my head didn't hurt, and I wasn't confused. And I expressed that to my husband on the walk home. And as I did, I started sobbing uncontrollably, because I suddenly realized, this is what it used to feel like to be in my brain.
——我没有迷失，头不疼，也没有困惑。我在回家的路上向我丈夫表达了这一点。就在那一刻，我开始无法抑制地啜泣，因为我突然意识到，这就是曾经作为正常大脑的感觉。
And I didn't even know how far off I was of being myself or being fully functioning. And so it was both an incredible moment of knowing, oh, I am going to get better, actually, and also real grief for the last 3 and 1/2 years, and also just my lack of even having known what I'd lost.
我甚至不知道自己离做回自己或完全正常运作有多远。所以那一刻既是一个意识到“噢，我其实会好起来”的绝妙瞬间，也是对自己过去3年半的真正哀悼，也是对自己甚至不知道自己失去了什么的感伤。
And by the end of six weeks, just like the doctor had said, she was totally cured.
到六周结束时，就像医生说的那样，她彻底治愈了。
It honestly just felt like a veil lifting off the world, like I'd been behind this screen that I didn't know I was behind. And my vision had adjusted to everything being a bit blurry. And then suddenly, everything was clear and in technicolor and beautiful.
真的感觉就像一层面纱从世界上揭开，就像我一直待在自己不知道身处的屏幕后面。而我的视力已经适应了一切变得有点模糊。然后突然间，一切都变得清晰、色彩鲜艳且美丽。
It's been five years since Sarah recovered. And not only is she symptom-free, she actually gained something that I never would have expected, and is the entire reason I wanted you to hear this story. That whole run towards the danger thing, it's pervaded the rest of her life. Instead of being all squirrely and avoidant when a big challenge comes along, now she's like, OK, bring it on.
莎拉康复已经五年了。不仅症状全无，她实际上还获得了一些我从未预料到的东西，这就是我希望你们听这个故事的全部原因。那种“冲向危险”的事情，已经渗透到了她生活的其他方面。当遇到巨大的挑战时，她不再胆怯和逃避，现在她心想，好吧，放马过来吧。
I do all kinds of things now that I am terrified of and that I would never do. Like, I now, if I'm asked to be on stage, it's very likely I will say yes because it's so hard for me. And I know the more I do it and the more I work with it, the better it's going to get. So I don't really avoid anything that bugs me anymore.
我现在做各种让我感到恐惧、以前绝不会做的事情。比如，现在如果有人请我上台表演，很可能我会答应，因为这对我很困难。我知道我做得越多，处理得越多，它就会变得越好。所以，我不再真正逃避任何让我烦恼的事情了。
I am so very honored to be asked to speak here today--
能受邀今天在这里演讲，我深感荣幸——
This is Sarah addressing graduates at the University of Toronto just a couple of months ago. She told the crowd she was terrified of being on stage, even as she was onstage speaking to them.
这是莎拉几个月前在多伦多大学向毕业生演讲的情景。她告诉人群，即使在台上向他们演讲，她也感到非常恐惧。
There are many things to be legitimately afraid of. Don't worry, I won't list them.
有很多事情是真正值得恐惧的。别担心，我不会列举它们。
She's also taken on huge projects that would have felt insurmountable to her before the concussion happened, like the movie Women Talking, which won her an Oscar last year for her screenplay. And that book I mentioned before, it's called Run Towards the Danger. And it's full of deeply personal, sometimes really upsetting, stories from her life that she'd always been scared to tell.
她还承担了巨大的项目，这些项目在脑震荡发生前对她来说是无法逾越的，比如电影《女性的谈话》，该片去年为她的剧本赢得了奥斯卡奖。我之前提到那本书，书名叫《冲向危险》。里面充满了她生活中深度个人、有时非常令人不安的故事，这些故事她一直害怕讲出来。
And is it literally, if you were going into some sort of uncomfortable situation, that you're thinking of the words "run towards the danger" now?
那是字面意思吗，如果你要进入某种不舒服的境地，你现在脑子里会想到“冲向危险”这几个字吗？
I do think it sometimes, but I don't have to because it gets lobbed at me more than I say it to myself. If you want to make your life a living hell, name a book Run Towards The Danger, because then any time you express reservation about anything, the person in the other corner will be like, I don't want to say it, but I don't know if you remember the title of your book.
我有时会这么想，但我不必刻意想，因为它被抛向我的次数比我对自已说出的次数多。如果你想让你的生活变成人间地狱，就把一本书命名为《冲向危险》，因为那时，当你对任何事情表达保留意见时，对方角落里的人会说，我不想说，但我不知道你还记不记得你的书名。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
It's so annoying.
这太烦人了。
Sarah says she's glad now for the concussion. Glad for a concussion. Her whole life, she says, she kept mixing up taking care of herself with avoiding anything potentially difficult or uncomfortable. Those two things can look very much the same, but they're not. And you can miss out on a lot in life when you confuse them. So she's happy to know the difference. And all it took was a fire extinguisher falling on her head.
莎拉说她现在为脑震荡感到庆幸。为脑震荡感到庆幸。她说，她的一生都在混淆照顾自己和逃避任何潜在困难或不舒服的事情。这两件事看起来非常相似，但并非如此。当你把它们混淆时，你会在生活中错过很多东西。所以她很高兴知道其中的区别。而这一切仅仅是因为一个灭火器砸在了她的头上。
Sean Cole is one of the producers of our show.
肖恩·科尔是我们节目的制片人之一。
Coming up, what do you do when your kid doesn't just fly the coop, but decides twice a week to head straight into danger? What parenting advice exists for that? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，当你的孩子不仅仅是离家独立，而且决定每周两次直面危险时，你该怎么办？有什么育儿建议吗？一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Swim Towards the Shark," stories of people who ignore all the noise that is in all of our heads that tells us to run away from danger, and instead, they head straight towards it.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目《游向鲨鱼》，讲述的是那些忽略了我们每个人脑海中让我们远离危险的所有杂音，反而直接冲向它的那些人的故事。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, "Am I Doing It Alt-Right, You Guys?" So this is about somebody who got into an incendiary situation, and then rather than pull herself out, decided, hmm, I'm just going to head further into that fire. Comedian Josh Johnson talked about what happened on stage recently. Here he is.
我们进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“我这样做算另类右翼吗，伙计们？”所以这是一个关于某人陷入煽动性境地，然后并没有把自己拉出来，而是决定，嗯，我要直接冲进那团火里的故事。喜剧演员乔什·约翰逊最近在舞台上谈到了发生的事情。他在那儿。
Did y'all see the white woman that got in trouble for saying the N-word? I know you're saying, which one? OK, fair enough.
你们有没有看到那个因为说N开头的单词而惹上麻烦的白人女性？我知道你们在说，哪一个？好的，公平合理。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
OK. I say "the" because this was "the" for me. It's like, other people were saying it. People were saying it all the time. But this one was like-- this one felt especially crazy. So I followed the story because it is captivating.
好的。我说“那个”是因为对我来说这是“那个”。就像，其他人也在说它。人们一直都在说它。但这一位就像——这一位感觉特别疯狂。所以我关注了这个故事，因为它很吸引人。
OK, so basically-- OK, where do I even start? There's a thing called trad wife. Now, trad wife is short for traditional wife, right? Trad wife is, like, this content thing that they do on TikTok. It's spilled over to Instagram a little bit.
好的，基本上——好的，我从哪开始呢？有一种东西叫“Trad Wife”（传统妻子）。现在，“Trad wife”是“Traditional wife”的缩写，对吧？“Trad wife”就是TikTok上她们做的一种内容。它已经稍微溢出到Instagram上了。
And it's basically women doing stuff around the house while telling women to be better women, right? It's just like, why don't you be a lady, while she makes a pie or something. I don't get it. It's not for me. I'm not who watches it. But basically, there was this young white woman that was over here cooking something. It didn't look done. And--
基本上就是女性在家里做一些事情，同时告诉女性要成为更好的女性，对吧？就像是，你为什么不做个淑女呢，而她正在烤派或者什么的。我不懂。这不是给我的。我不是看这个的人。但基本上，有个年轻白人女性在这儿煮东西。看起来还没熟。然后——
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Maybe it was done. Maybe she's bad at it-- I don't know. But it did not look done. But then she's talking about her friends. And then she says, 'cause then some of my friends out here are just, like, out here dating these guys and broke-ass [BLEEP] right? And she says it. She says it without missing a beat. She says it like you're not going to hear it, right?
也许熟了。也许她不擅长——我不知道。但它看起来不像熟了。但她正在谈论她的朋友。然后她说，因为我的朋友们都在这儿跟这些男人约会，都是些穷酸的[哔——]，对吧？她说了。她说出来的时候连停顿都没停顿。她说得就像你听不见一样，对吧？
So then, of course, everyone who saw this, it started this frenzy online, right? And so there were all these people-- she did it on TikTok. There was all these people commenting, replying, what's wrong with you? What are you doing? Are you trolling? All stuff like that, right? And then she makes another video. And she's like, look, I made a video earlier that offended a community or something.
所以当然，所有看到这一幕的人都在网上引发了一阵狂热，对吧？所以有很多人——她在TikTok上做的。有很多人评论、回复，你怎么了？你在干什么？你在钓鱼吗？所有诸如此类的事情，对吧？然后她又做了一个视频。她说，看，我之前做了一个冒犯了一个群体的视频什么的。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
And I've really listened to the feedback. And I'm not going to lie-- I don't really give a care. Like, I don't know. So then they found her job, right, which is crazy, because you're a trad wife. Why are you working? Why are you--
而且我真的听取了反馈。我不撒谎——我真的不在乎。就像，我不知道。所以后来他们找到了她的工作，对吧，这很疯狂，因为你是个传统妻子。你为什么要工作？为什么——
[LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE]
（笑声、掌声）
You know what I mean? You know what I mean? Why are you-- you're supposed to be a traditional-- why are you working at all? You can't trad wife on the side. You can't--
你知道我的意思吗？你知道我的意思吗？你为什么要——你本应该是传统的——你为什么要工作？你不能在业余时间做传统妻子。你不能——
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
There's no such thing as halfway crooks. You know what I mean? You got to be all in or all out, right? And so then they found her job. Then they got her fired from her job, right? So then everyone was talking about how she clearly got fired. Even though they don't say her name, they issued a press release, because why else would they do it? And they were like, yeah, certain individual's not working here anymore.
没有什么“半路出家”的骗子。你知道我的意思吗？你必须全身心投入，否则就别干，对吧？所以后来他们找到了她的工作。然后他们让她被解雇了，对吧？所以每个人都在谈论她显然被解雇了。尽管他们没有说她的名字，但他们发布了新闻稿，因为他们为什么要这么做呢？他们说，是的，某位个人不再在这里工作了。
So then, so then, she starts trying to cozy up to Newsmax and One Nation News and just a lot of the alt-right on Twitter and everything. And she takes this spin of, I was canceled, right? But she also just doesn't quite have the juice. You know what I mean by that? She doesn't quite have the presence and the energy of a real racist is going to be a newscaster. You know what I mean?
所以后来，她开始试图讨好Newsmax、One Nation News以及推特上的很多另类右翼，等等。她采取的立场是，我被取消了，对吧？但她也没有足够的能力。你明白我说的那个意思吗？她并没有真正种族主义者的那种存在感和能量，能去当新闻播音员。你知道我的意思吗？
She just doesn't have "it." Like when you're watching her, you're like, she's saying bad things, and they're annoying, but I'm not angry. She just doesn't have the oomph to get me there. You know what I mean? I've just never seen diet racism before, but that was it.
她就是没有“那个劲儿”。就像你看她的时候，你觉得，她在说坏话，它们很烦人，但我并不生气。她就是没有那个让我到达那种程度的力量。你知道我的意思吗？我从未见过低配版种族主义，但这就是。
So then she makes more videos, trying to double down harder. And in these upcoming videos, she just gets way worse with it, gets even more bigoted with it. So she's tweeting the N-word all the time. She's been tweeting the N-word non-stop since she got fired, right? And now, she's making videos where she's saying the F-word, right? And so, she's just going after everybody, just trying to prove how terrible that she is, right?
所以她做了更多的视频，试图变本加厉。在这些即将发布的视频中，她变得更糟糕了，偏执得更厉害。所以她一直在推特上发N开头的单词。她被解雇后一直在不停地发那个词，对吧？现在，她正在制作视频，说F开头的那个词，对吧？所以，她只是在攻击所有人，试图证明她有多糟糕，对吧？
And so then she starts trying to cozy up to a lot of these especially neo-Nazis as much as she can. And then, then, a turn takes place, an incredible turn that I could not have predicted, one of the most insane things that has maybe happened so far this century-- the neo-Nazis start rejecting her as a PSYOP. They--
所以她开始试图讨好很多这些极端的、甚至是新纳粹分子，尽可能多地讨好。然后，然后，发生了一个转折，一个我无法预测的不可思议的转折，可能是本世纪迄今为止发生的最疯狂的事情之一——新纳粹开始把她当作心理战行动（PSYOP）拒绝她。他们——
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Because they feel what I feel. They see the video, and they're like, mm, you don't mean it, though. It's not--
因为他们感觉到了我所感受到的。他们看到视频，就像是，嗯，你不是真心的，对吧。它不是——
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
It's not, like, coming out of your stomach. You know what I mean? Like, it's not-- you're not even saying it with bass, you know? You know? And so then, they were like, no, no, don't trust her, OK? Don't listen to her. Don't follow her. She's working for the CIA. She's probably a Fed. They all turned on her. They started bullying her.
就像，它没有从你的胃里发出来。你知道我的意思吗？就像，它不是——你连说的时候都没有低音，你知道吗？你知道？所以后来，他们就像，不，不，别相信她，好的？别听她的。别关注她。她是为中央情报局工作的。她可能是个联邦探员。他们都倒戈了。他们开始霸凌她。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
It was absolutely insane. It was one of those things where, then, she keeps trying to cozy up to them. She keeps trying to take pictures with them. She's going to events and stuff like that. And some of the ones that roll with her are rolling with her in real-time, you know? And they're making fun of how other people are making fun of her. But you can tell she's still not in yet, you know? She's not with them, hard.
这绝对是疯了。这是那种事情之一，她一直在试图讨好他们。她一直在试图和他们拍照。她去参加活动之类的。有些人跟着她，实时跟着她，你知道吗？他们在拿别人怎么取笑她来取笑她。但你能看出她还没进去，你知道吗？她还没和他们混在一起，没那么坚决。
And she just played it-- she played it poorly. That's what happened. She could have had a real shot. She could have. But she doesn't have enough of the real-- you can tell she's not really racist.
她只是打得——她打得很烂。就是这么回事。她本可以有个真正的机会。她本可以的。但她没有足够的真正的——你能看出她不是真正的种族主义者。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
I know it's a weird thing to say about somebody who's been saying the N-word non-stop for a week, but you can just tell she doesn't have the fire in her. You know? That's not how you do it. You are making racist people uncomfortable. You are making--
我知道对于一个持续一周不停说N开头单词的人说这种话很奇怪，但你就是能看出她没有那种火候。你知道吗？这不是你做事的方式。你是在让种族主义者感到不舒服。你是在让——
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
That's not how you do it. If you really want to be somebody as a racist, if you really want to make waves as a bigot, you start out slow. You start with a bunch of slow and steady dog whistles over decades. I mean, you never say the word outright. You throw out a "thug" here every once in a while. You know what I mean?
这不是你做事的方式。如果你真的想作为一个种族主义者出人头地，如果你真的想作为一个偏执狂掀起波澜，你要从慢开始。你要从几十年的那种缓慢而稳定的暗示开始。我的意思是，你从不直接说那个词。你偶尔会扔出一个“暴徒”。你知道我的意思吗？
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Every once in a while, like on a holiday, you can get real crazy with it. You can do, like, an "animals" or something. It's like, get people going, you know? Plant your feet, but don't dig too deep.
每隔一段时间，比如在节日里，你可以变得很疯狂。你可以做，比如，一个“动物”什么的。就像，让人们行动起来，你知道吗？站稳脚跟，但不要挖得太深。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
And then after a while, you start to ingratiate yourself. They start to be like, hey, she's one of us. And then they bring in, and maybe they bring you in on a temporary basis. And they give you a little guest spot every now and again. And then after a couple of decades, you get a hosting gig, you know? Because be honest-- like, if a week from now, Megyn Kelly said the N-word, we'd be like, yep.
然后过了一会儿，你开始迎合他们。他们开始觉得，嘿，她是我们的一员。然后他们把你带进来，也许他们会让你临时参与。他们偶尔给你一个小小的客串机会。然后几十年后，你得到一个主持工作，你知道吗？因为说实话——如果一周后，梅根·凯利说了那个词，我们会说，是的。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
We expected that. She's been earning it over decades. The expectation lands right on the strip perfectly. And then, then, we also find out that she might be single. So you're not only not a trad wife, you're not a wife. What are you doing?
我们预料到了。她几十年来一直在挣这个头衔。那个期望完美地落在了条子上。然后，然后，我们也发现她可能单身。所以你不仅不是传统妻子，你连妻子都不是。你在干什么？
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
What are you doing? Where's your man right now? She really put herself in the position where she really needs a husband.
你在干什么？你的男人现在在哪儿？她真的让自己处于那种非常需要丈夫的位置。
[LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE]
（笑声、掌声）
Josh Johnson performing in Philadelphia. He's a correspondent for The Daily Show, currently on a nationwide stand-up tour. To learn when he is coming to your city, go to joshjohnsoncomedy.com.
乔什·约翰逊在费城的表演。他是《每日秀》的通讯员，目前正在进行全国单口喜剧巡演。要了解他什么时候来你的城市，请访问joshjohnsoncomedy.com。
We did reach out to the woman who he told that story about. Her name is Lilly Gaddis. Just to be perfectly accurate, she was never on Newsmax or One Nation News, but she did appear on similar outlets-- InfoWars, Candace Owens.
我们确实联系了那个他讲过故事的女人。她的名字是莉莉·加迪斯。为了准确起见，她从未在Newsmax或One Nation News上工作过，但她确实出现在类似的媒体上——InfoWars，坎迪斯·欧文斯。
She wrote us back right away. She said, hey, thanks for reaching out. Yes, I've seen this bit. It's fairly accurate, except for the trad wife part. I never claimed at any time to be a trad wife. It's actually a funny bit. She signed it, "Cheers, Lilly."
她立刻回信了。她说，嘿，谢谢你们联系。是的，我看过这个段子。除了“传统妻子”那部分，它相当准确。我从来没有在任何时候自称是传统妻子。这其实是个有趣的段子。她签名为“干杯，莉莉”。
Act Three, "Mom Thinks He Doth Protest Too Much." So now a story where lots of people are running towards peril. Reporter Kimu Elolia grew up going to Kenya every year for a month or so. And so this June, he went back, like usual.
第三幕，“妈妈认为他抗议得太过分了”。这是一个许多人冲向危险的故事。记者金木·埃洛利亚每年都会回肯尼亚待上一个月左右。所以今年六月，他和往常一样回去了。
So I go into a store and do what I always do. I go to buy a SIM card. And as I'm checking out, I start hearing all these noises coming from the street. And so I step out, and it's hundreds of protesters that are sprinting towards me. And they're all being chased by the police. And I realize I'm directly in the front lines of a protest. And so I had my recorder on me, and so I turned it on.
我走进一家商店，做我总是做的事。我去买一张SIM卡。当我在结账时，我开始听到街上传来各种噪音。我走出去，那是几百名正向我冲来的抗议者。他们都被警察追赶。我意识到我直接站在了抗议的前线。我身上带着录音机，所以我就打开了它。
[EXPLOSION]
（爆炸声）
I'm seeing police on horseback chasing protesters, going around with wooden sticks and just beating people as they rode through, and then protesters retaliating and running back and chasing the police. And then they kind of regain their ground.
我看到骑马的警察追赶抗议者，拿着木棍四处走动，骑马冲过时就开始殴打人们，然后抗议者反击并跑回去追赶警察。然后他们重新占领了阵地。
Oh, so the line is moving forward and backward.
哦，所以战线在向前和向后移动。
Yeah, it's going back and forth. And police are shooting tear gas canisters. One of them hits a guy in the leg, and he picks it up and drop kicks it like a soccer ball back towards the police.
是的，它在来回移动。警察在发射催泪瓦斯罐。其中一个击中了一个人的腿，他把它捡起来，像踢足球一样把它踢回警察那边。
And these protests began a couple of months ago over a proposed tax hike, right?
这些抗议活动是几个月前因为提议提高税收而开始的，对吧？
Yeah, there were these really punitive tax hikes impacting a lot of Kenyan everyday items, like cooking oil, flour, tampons, even diapers.
是的，有一些非常惩罚性的增税影响了许多肯尼亚的日常用品，比如食用油、面粉、卫生棉条，甚至尿布。
And this is the sort of thing, like, the government needed the money because there's IMF loans and stuff to pay off?
政府需要这些钱，因为有国际货币基金组织的贷款和之类的东西要偿还？
Yeah, it was supposed to be the solution to pay back the IMF.
是的，它本应是偿还国际货币基金组织的解决方案。
But then it became something more than that.
但后来它变得不仅仅是那样了。
Yeah, it became this huge movement where people, especially young people, were just rejecting just the status quo of the way the Kenyan government's been operating. Politicians flaunting their Rolex watches, their Bentleys.
是的，它变成了一场巨大的运动，人们，特别是年轻人，只是拒绝了肯尼亚政府运作方式的现状。政客们炫耀他们的劳力士手表，他们的宾利汽车。
This is on social media.
这是在社交媒体上。
On social media, while they're being asked to pay for way more for these regular everyday items. And young people make up-- 75% of the population is under 35.
在社交媒体上，而他们被要求为这些常规日常用品支付更多的费用。年轻人占人口的比例——75%的人口在35岁以下。
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
Yeah, and the median age in the country is around 20 years old. And this young generation, they're crossing tribal lines. In the past, tribes, they typically act like de facto political parties. And so one tribe will gain control of the country, and another tribe will be protesting.
是的，这个国家的年龄中位数在20岁左右。年轻一代，他们正在跨越部落界限。在过去，部落通常充当事实上的政党。所以一个部落将获得国家的控制权，另一个部落将会抗议。
Oh, so now people from different tribes are protesting together in this way that's new.
哦，所以现在来自不同部落的人正在以这种新的方式一起抗议。
Yeah, these young people are united. And they really just see themselves as Kenyans.
是的，这些年轻人是团结的。他们真的只是把自己视为肯尼亚人。
So I know that you got interested in the front line protesters who go to the part of the line where it's the most dangerous. And you started talking to one of them and his mom. Who is he?
所以我知道你对前线抗议者感兴趣，他们去最危险的一线。你开始和他们中的一个以及他的妈妈交谈。他是谁？
So he goes by Ospina. Ospina is 27. He's a law student. My sister introduced me to him, and she was telling me about this guy who-- he's in Kibera, which is a neighborhood in Nairobi. It's one of the largest slums in all of Africa. You really can't go anywhere in the neighborhood without seeing the places he's touched and the projects he's done.
他叫奥斯皮纳。奥斯皮纳27岁。他是法学院学生。我姐姐把我介绍给他，她跟我说这个家伙——他在基贝拉，那是内罗毕的一个社区。它是整个非洲最大的贫民窟之一。在那个社区里，你真的走到哪里都能看到他留下的足迹和他做过的项目。
And in these protests, he's going to the front lines, where most of the violence and arrests are happening.
在这些抗议活动中，他去最前线，那里发生着最严重的暴力和逮捕。
Yeah, and because it's so dangerous, before he goes out each time, he says a prayer to himself.
是的，因为太危险了，每次出去之前，他都会向自己祈祷。
So, God, as I'm leaving this place, protect me, guide me, and be with me. Bless our country. Be with my family. Bless my mother. I know she's praying with me. Amen.
所以，上帝，当我离开这个地方时，保护我，指引我，与我同在。祝福我们的国家。与我的家人同在。祝福我的母亲。我知道她和我一起祈祷。阿门。
He's saying at the end there, bless my mother. What does his mom think of this, the fact that he goes to the front lines?
他在结尾说祝福我的母亲。他妈妈怎么看这件事，他去前线的事？
His mom does not approve. She does not want him going at all.
他妈妈不支持。她根本不想让他去。
And you put together this story about what this has done to the relationship and how they're managing with each other. Let's hear that now. In your story, the name that she asked us to call her is Anna.
你整理了这个关于这对他关系造成的影响以及他们如何相处的故事。让我们现在听听那个。在你的故事里，她要求我们称呼她的名字是安娜。
In the beginning, when he started going to the protests, Ospina dealt with his mom by lying to her. He'd come back home from the front lines, shower the tear gas off, and drop by her house, pretending he'd been having a normal day. But he wasn't so good at keeping it a secret. Like, one day, at a protest, a TV crew put a mic in front of him and started interviewing him. Anna found out.
起初，当他开始去抗议时，奥斯皮纳通过撒谎来应付妈妈。他会从前线回家，洗掉催泪瓦斯，顺便去她家，假装自己过着正常的一天。但他不太擅长保密。有一天，在抗议现场，一个电视摄制组把麦克风放在他面前开始采访他。安娜发现了。
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
My friend called me and told me that they have seen Ospina on TV. So I was calling Ospina.
我朋友打电话给我，告诉我他们已经在电视上看到奥斯皮纳了。所以我打电话给奥斯皮纳。
I was just at the middle of finishing my interview. Then the phone was ringing. Then I just see, ah, it's Mom. This woman is going to make it difficult for me.
我当时正要完成我的采访。然后电话响了。然后我看到，啊，是妈妈。这个女人要让我的日子难过了。
And I was like, where are you? And he was just not telling me. Then I was like, you were on TV for the protest. And he just kept laughing.
我问，你在哪里？他就是不告诉我。然后我说，你在电视上抗议。他只是不停地笑。
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
My mom is funny when she's angry. She just starts yelling. [CHUCKLES] I'm like, I'm just home. Then she's like, you're lying. I've seen you on TV. Then I'm like, are you sure? Which station did you see me? I'm just home. Then she's like, I need you to come back right now.
我妈妈生气的时候很有趣。她只是开始大喊大叫。（轻笑）我当时说，我正在家里。然后她说，你在撒谎。我在电视上看见你了。然后我说，你确定吗？你在哪个台看见我的？我正在家里。然后她说，我需要你马上回来。
He was laughing, telling his friends, like, oh, my mom is panicked.
他在笑，告诉他的朋友们，就像，哦，我妈妈惊慌失措了。
[CHUCKLING]
（轻笑）
Ospina and Anna have always been close. They talk all the time and tease each other. He lives a 10-minute walk away. Sometimes he'll bring his friends to the food stand she runs. It's called Mama Chapati. She's there all day in a blue or white dress. Ospina looks just like her. And over the years, he's done other stuff she didn't approve of at first and later came around to, like soccer, or football, whatever you want to call it.
奥斯皮纳和安娜一直很亲近。他们总是聊天，互相调侃。他住在步行10分钟远的地方。有时他会带朋友去她经营的食品摊。它叫“妈妈查帕蒂”（Mama Chapati）。她整天穿着蓝色或白色的裙子待在那里。奥斯皮纳长得就像她。多年来，他做过其他她起初不赞同后来又接受的事情，比如足球，或者无论你管它叫什么。
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
He was keen on football. He used to play a lot. And I didn't see any value in playing football. In fact, it was such a nuisance because he'd come back home so dirty.
他很热衷足球。他过去常玩很多。我没看出踢球有什么价值。事实上，那真是一个麻烦，因为他回家时总是那么脏。
Then, when Ospina was 14, Anna and her husband couldn't afford to send him to school for a year. Anna says he took it well. She said he understood and was very grown-up about it. And then he took on odd jobs and played a lot of soccer. And she saw how happy it made him. He played so well that two soccer scouts got him a scholarship that put him back in the classroom.
然后，当奥斯皮纳14岁时，安娜和丈夫负担不起让他上学一年。安娜说他接受得很好。她说他理解，并且表现得非常成熟。后来他做些零工，踢了很多足球。她看到了这让他有多开心。他踢得太好了，两个足球球探给了他奖学金，让他回到了课堂。
Anna was grateful. She grew up in a village and only got through the fifth grade and wanted more for her kids. A similar thing happened when Ospina decided to clean up their neighborhood. Kibera at the time had no roads, no streetlights, no trash collection. At first, when he told Anna he was going to pick up the trash himself, she thought he was joking. But within a few years, he was coordinating trash pickups for hundreds of houses. And she came around.
安娜很感激。她在村子里长大，只读到了五年级，希望她的孩子们有更好的未来。当奥斯皮纳决定清理他们的社区时，类似的事情也发生了。当时的基贝拉没有道路，没有路灯，没有垃圾收集。起初，当他告诉安娜他要自己捡垃圾时，她以为他在开玩笑。但在几年内，他就在为数百户人家协调垃圾回收了。她最终接受了。
Ospina has so many projects going in Kibera these days-- organizing events and mentorship for kids, a greenhouse that grows and sells food, a water sanitation program-- lots of neighbors are pinning their hopes on him.
奥斯皮纳这些天在基贝拉开展了许多项目——为孩子们组织活动和指导，一个种植和销售食物的温室，一个水卫生项目——许多邻居把希望寄托在他身上。
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
A lot of parents support him because he's helping their kids. What I tried to tell him-- and he never listens, and I never get across to him-- is how important he is to me. He is very, very important to me. And he has such a wonderful dream for our future, for the future of Kenya. So he told me about these dreams. He gave me these hopes.
很多家长支持他，因为他在帮助他们的孩子。我试着告诉他——但他从不听，我也从不让他明白——他对我有多重要。他对我非常非常重要。他为我们的未来，为肯尼亚的未来有着如此美好的梦想。所以他告诉我这些梦想。他给了我这些希望。
Up until now, Anna has liked Ospina's optimism. She liked the way he's pushed her. But she's lived through years of de facto one-party rule, seen protests get ruthlessly put down and activists get killed. And this time around, she doesn't understand where Ospina is coming from.
直到现在，安娜都很喜欢奥斯皮纳的乐观。她喜欢他推动她的方式。但她经历过多年的事实上一党统治，目睹过抗议活动被无情镇压，活动人士被杀害。而这一次，她不理解奥斯皮纳从何而来。
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
Most of the time, he listens. But recently, he's just been deciding that I'm just someone who's afraid all the time, and I'm speaking out of fear. So he doesn't listen.
大多数时候，他听从。但最近，他只是认定我是一个总是害怕的人，我在出于恐惧说话。所以他不听。
Why do you feel like he thinks you're just speaking out of fear?
为什么你觉得他认为你只是出于恐惧说话？
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
I think it's just an assumption, because I'm a woman, and I'm a mother. And men just assume that we are, we are always talking from fear.
我觉得这只是一个假设，因为我是个女人，是个母亲。男人们只是认为我们总是出于恐惧而说话。
Do you think that, in this case, it is out of fear?
你认为在这种情况下，这是出于恐惧吗？
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Yes, he's right. Yeah, he's right. It's right. It was fear.
是的，他是对的。是的，他是对的。是对的。那是恐惧。
For the first few weeks of the protest, Anna and Ospina went back and forth, her telling him not to go, him lying to her, until things reached a boiling point on June 25.
在抗议活动的最初几周，安娜和奥斯皮纳来来回回，她告诉他不要去，他跟她撒谎，直到6月25日达到了沸点。
Members of parliament have today passed the controversial finance bill with key amendments. The bill will now be forwarded to President William Ruto for assent.
议会议员们今天通过了有争议的财政法案，并进行了关键修订。该法案现在将转交给威廉·鲁托总统签署。
Instead of killing the tax hikes like the protesters demanded, Kenya's parliament just made a few changes and pushed the bill through. And in response, Ospina and thousands of other protesters rushed to parliament, stormed the building, and some set part of it on fire on live TV. I remember it felt like the whole country was watching. It got violent.
肯尼亚议会并没有像抗议者要求的那样取消增税，而是做了一些修改并强行通过了法案。作为回应，奥斯皮纳和成千上万的其他抗议者冲向议会，冲进大楼，一些人在直播中点燃了它。我记得感觉整个国家都在观看。它变得暴力了。
[GUNFIRE]
（枪声）
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
A young kid from the neighborhood, came, and he was buying food from me. But he was out of breath, and he told me, Mom, they killed someone in front of me. And I saw his brains, and I had to crawl out. And I'm so, so lucky to have made it out. And you could see in his eyes that he has seen things that he shouldn't see, shouldn't have seen.
社区里的一个年轻人来了，他在买我的食物。但他上气不接下气，他告诉我，妈妈，他们在我面前杀了一个人。我看见了他的脑浆，我不得不爬出来。我太幸运了能逃出来。你可以从他的眼睛里看出他看到了不该看的东西。
That must have made you really scared.
那一定让你非常害怕。
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
I was so scared because Ospina had said that they were going to go to parliament. And I tried calling his phone. I tried calling his phone. And his phone-- I couldn't reach him. I kept getting this voice message.
我太害怕了，因为奥斯皮纳说他们要去议会。我试着打他的电话。我一直打他的电话。而他的电话——我联系不上他。我一直收到这个语音留言。
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
I was restless. My stomach hurt. I had no energy. And I felt like something very bad is about to happen to someone that I depend on, someone who has my hopes, was the carrier of my hopes.
我坐立不安。我的胃很痛。我没有力气。我觉得我依赖的人，寄托我希望的人，承载我希望的人，就要发生非常糟糕的事情了。
Over a dozen people were killed. Anna called Ospina over and over, started asking people who passed her chapati stand if they'd seen him, called his siblings, called his friends, praying he'd pick up the phone. Then her daughter told her about something she saw on TV.
十几个人被杀。安娜一遍又一遍地给奥斯皮纳打电话，开始询问路过她查帕蒂摊位的人是否见过他，给他的兄弟姐妹打电话，给他的朋友打电话，祈祷他能接电话。然后她的女儿告诉了她关于她在电视上看到的事情。
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
Lillian, my daughter, came and told me that she'd seen someone who was dressed exactly like Ospina who had been shot. And he was wearing the exact same shoes that Ospina was wearing. So I was so anxious. I couldn't-- I hadn't-- like, everything left me. All my life left me.
莉莲，我的女儿，过来说她看到一个穿得和奥斯皮纳一模一样的人被枪击了。而且他穿着奥斯皮纳穿的一模一样的鞋子。所以我太焦虑了。我无法——我没有——一切都离我而去。我所有的生命都离我而去。
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
Because my hopes and dreams and future lies with those children.
因为我的希望、梦想和未来都在那些孩子身上。
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
So if something happens to them, how can I continue going on? And I kept wondering how my life will be if that's actually my child.
所以如果他们发生了什么事，我怎么能继续活下去？我一直想知道如果那真的是我的孩子，我的生活会是什么样子。
Finally, at around 9:00 PM, one of Ospina's friends called. Ospina was OK. Anna rushed out to meet him, and she found him in the middle of the street.
终于，在晚上9点左右，奥斯皮纳的一个朋友打了电话。奥斯皮纳没事。安娜冲出去见他，她在街中间找到了他。
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
The first thing I told him, like, I thank god that you are still alive, but please don't ever go back to the protests. And he said, I have to go. And I told him, listen to me, I'm your parent. If something happens to you, Kenya is not losing anything. I am the person that's losing. I'm losing you.
我告诉他的第一件事，比如，我感谢上帝你还活着，但请永远不要再回抗议现场了。他说，我必须去。我对他说，听着，我是你的父母。如果如果你发生什么事，肯尼亚不会失去任何东西。失去的人是我。我失去的是你。
But he was adamant that he has to go back. He was, like, high with energy, explaining everything that happened with so much gusto. And meanwhile, I'm shaking. And I'm like, this child doesn't know what he put me through.
但他坚持他必须回去。他就像是被能量打过兴奋剂一样，解释着发生的一切，热情洋溢。与此同时，我在发抖。我想，这个孩子不知道他让我经历了什么。
Yeah, I mean, it just made me feel like she just doesn't understand why I'm doing whatever I'm doing. I mean, my mom is not comfortable with me being an activist because she's like, just relax. Have a family, you know? So, I mean, that is why sometimes we don't get along. And I find it so difficult sometimes to keep on repeating it.
是的，我的意思是，这让我觉得她就是不明白我为什么要那样做。我的意思是，我妈妈不舒服我成为一名活动家，因为她心想，放松点。成个家，你知道吗？所以，这就是为什么有时候我们相处不来。我发现有时候一遍又一遍重复它太困难了。
Ospina felt like, I'm responsible, and I do everything I can to get home safely. He wished his mom could see that. He went back to his place and turned off his phone, shutting everyone out.
奥斯皮纳觉得，我是有责任的，我尽我所能安全回家。他希望他妈妈能看到这一点。他回到住处关掉了电话，把每个人都隔绝在外。
Two days later, Ospina stopped by Anna's chapati stand with some of his friends and told her they were headed to another demonstration. In front of everyone on the street, including his friends, Anna dropped to her knees.
两天后，奥斯皮纳带着一些朋友顺路来到安娜的查帕蒂摊位，告诉她他们正要去参加另一次示威。在街上的每个人面前，包括他的朋友们，安娜跪了下来。
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
I knew that I had to do something that will make them think, what has made Mom go down on her knees? Maybe this is something we should rethink.
我知道我必须做些什么让他们思考，是什么让妈妈跪下来了？也许这是我们应该重新考虑的事情。
Mm. That's such a vulnerable thing to do. Some people would feel humiliated.
嗯。那真是非常脆弱的表现。有些人会觉得屈辱。
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
I didn't care about shame. In fact, people were laughing. Spectators were laughing.
我不在乎羞耻。事实上，人们在笑。围观者在笑。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
They were laughing?
他们在笑？
They were laughing, pointing at me, telling each other, look, Mama Chapati is so afraid. His kids are going to go and protest.
他们在笑，指着我，互相说，看，妈妈查帕蒂太害怕了。他的孩子要去抗议。
What did you see in his face at that moment?
那一刻你在他的脸上看到了什么？
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
So in his face, I saw denial. It's like he did not want to hear me say what I wanted to say.
所以在他脸上，我看到了否认。好像他不想听到我想说的话。
Mm, so--
嗯，所以——
Yeah.
是的。
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
I mean, it was so insane. I just had to leave.
我的意思是，那太疯狂了。我不得不离开。
Oh, you walked out?
哦，你走开了？
Yeah, I just walked out.
是的，我就走开了。
Why?
为什么？
I've never seen such a thing. And from my understanding, it's not allowed to be happening. So I was like, this is so weird. So I cannot just stay there because I don't know the best thing to do. I can't comfort her. I can't explain anything, you know.
我从未见过这样的事。据我理解，这种事是不允许发生的。所以我心想，这太奇怪了。所以我不能就待在那儿，因为我不知道最好的办法是什么。我不能安慰她。我不能解释任何事，你知道。
Ospina walked away, went to the protests. But that night, the image of his mom kneeling, begging, it weighed on his mind.
奥斯皮纳走开了，去了抗议现场。但那天晚上，他妈妈下跪乞求的画面在他脑海中挥之不去。
That was massive because, I mean, I felt like she'd gone too low. I actually found it so difficult to sleep. I had a lot of anxiety. Then I was like, I need to take some few break, reflect, and make a good choice.
那太震撼了，因为我的意思是，我觉得她已经卑微到了极点。我实际上发现很难入睡。我非常焦虑。我心想，我需要休息一下，反思一下，做出一个好的选择。
The next day, Ospina went to visit his mom.
第二天，奥斯皮纳去探望他的母亲。
First of all, I started by apologizing for not listening, putting her in that situation and all the emotion to make me feel like I'm listening to her.
首先，我从道歉开始，为没有听她的话，让她陷入那种境地，所有那些情感道歉，让我感觉到我在倾听她。
Did you promise her anything in that moment?
那一刻你向她承诺了什么吗？
Yes. First, I promised to just to tell her the truth, that anytime I'll be going for the protest, I'll be letting her know. Then anytime I felt like it was so dangerous, I will not be going. If it's bad, I will just be there for a few moments, and I'll try to be very responsible.
是的。首先，我承诺只是告诉她真相，每当我去抗议时，我会告诉她。然后每当我感到它太危险时，我就不会去。如果情况很糟，我只会待一会儿，我会尽量表现得非常负责。
Did she feel like that was good enough for her?
她觉得这对他来说足够了吗？
No, not really.
不，没有。
Do you know what else-- what else did she want to hear?
你知道还有什么——她还想听到什么？
She just wanted to hear [LAUGHS] I will not go. I will never go again.
她只是想听到（笑）我不会去的。我再也不会去了。
Even though Anna didn't get what she wanted-- Ospina would continue to go to the protests-- she was satisfied.
尽管安娜没有得到她想要的——奥斯皮纳将继续去抗议——但她满足了。
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
Yeah, so I saw that, now, he's listening. And yeah.
是的，所以我看到，现在，他在听了。是的。
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
I was so happy. I had to be happy.
我太开心了。我必须开心。
Yeah. Did you celebrate?
是的。你们庆祝了吗？
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
A lot.
很多。
That night, she cooked a special meal for Ospina and her entire family.
那天晚上，她为奥斯皮纳和她的整个家庭做了一顿特别的饭。
In the weeks after the parliament protests, the president actually made some pretty big concessions, but not enough for the protesters, who still want him out. They're still on the streets, and it's gotten more intense.
在议会抗议后的几周里，总统实际上做出了一些相当大的让步，但对那些仍想让他下台的抗议者来说还不够。他们还在街上，情况变得更加紧张。
Amnesty International says that at least 49 people have been abducted by the government. Protesters have been disappeared, with a couple showing up dead. At first, the government denied any involvement, but now, President Ruto is at least talking about possible investigations.
国际特赦组织表示，至少有49人被政府绑架。抗议者失踪了，有几个人被发现死了。起初，政府否认有任何参与，但现在，鲁托总统至少在谈论可能的调查。
Ospina skipped a couple of protests because they seemed too dangerous, like a planned march to the Nairobi airport. But he is having a hard time keeping all of his promises to Anna.
奥斯皮纳错过了几次抗议，因为它们看起来太危险了，比如计划好的向内罗毕机场的游行。但他很难遵守对安娜的所有承诺。
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
So there are times when he disappears for a whole day. And then when he comes back, I'm like, I know you went to the protest. And sometimes, he'll admit and be like, OK, fine. I went, but I wasn't in the front lines. I was at the very back.
所以有时候他会整天失踪。然后当他回来时，我心想，我知道你去抗议了。有时候，他会承认，就像，好的，好吧。我去过，但我没在前线。我在最后面。
Do you believe that he was at the back?
你相信他在后面吗？
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
I don't believe it at all, not for a second.
我一点也不相信，一秒钟也不信。
How does it make you feel that he lies to you about going to the protest?
他向你隐瞒去抗议这件事，这让你感觉如何？
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
I'm so annoyed by that, by the lies. And I'm so afraid for him.
我对谎言感到非常恼火。而且我为他感到非常害怕。
Mm. He told us that he lies to you because he doesn't want to burden you. How does that make you feel?
嗯。他告诉我们他向你撒谎是因为他不想给你带来负担。这让你感觉如何？
[SPEAKING SWAHILI]
（斯瓦希里语发言）
I just keep wondering why he wants to die so early, and he has so much to do. Why?
我只是不停地想，为什么他想死得这么早，他还有那么多事情要做。为什么？
So here they both are. He's not going to change, and she's not going to feel better about it. So he keeps heading off into danger, and she keeps hoping for the best. And the protests just continue.
所以他们都在这里。他不会改变，她也不会感觉更好。所以他继续冲向危险，而她继续祈祷一切顺利。抗议活动还在继续。
Kimu Elolia. This story was produced by Emmanuel Dzotsi with additional reporting by Henry Larson. Vincho Nchogu translated what Anna was saying. Additional translation by Happiness Bulugu.
金木·埃洛利亚。这个故事由伊曼纽尔·佐齐制作，亨利·拉尔森进行补充报道。文乔·恩乔古翻译了安娜的话。额外的翻译由哈皮内斯·布鲁古提供。
["THE SHARK FIGHTER!" BY THE AQUABATS!]
（《鲨鱼斗士！》-水族人乐队）
Well, our program was produced today by Sean Cole. The people who put together today's show include Phia Bennin, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Ike Sriskandarajah, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
好吧，我们今天的节目由肖恩·科尔制作。制作今天节目的人包括菲亚·本宁、迈克尔·科米特、阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德、塞思·林德、托宾·洛、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、阿丽莎·希普、艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。我们的执行编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜勒拉赫曼。我们的资深编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。
Special thanks today to Virginia Smith, Elisabeth Calamari, Beth Mausteller, Sammie Kosslow, Nathan Zasler, John Leddy, Irungu Houghton and Amnesty International Kenya, Ernest Cornel at the Kenya Human Rights Coalition, Joshua Changwony, Theo Among, and Amanda Sperber.
今天特别感谢弗吉尼亚·史密斯、伊丽莎白·卡拉马里、贝丝·莫斯特勒、萨米·科斯洛、内森·扎斯勒、约翰·莱迪、伊伦古·霍顿和肯尼亚国际特赦组织、肯尼亚人权联盟的欧内斯特·科内尔、约书亚·张沃尼、西奥·阿蒙和阿曼达·斯珀伯。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free on your summer road trips or wherever. Again, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He and I have been debating what costumes we're going to wear to this year's Star Trek convention. He always wants us to be Vulcans, like Mr. Spock.
我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体播放我们800多集的档案，无论是在你的夏季公路旅行还是其他地方。再次强调，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交换中心）提供给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。他和我在讨论我们今年要穿什么服装参加星际迷航大会。他总是希望我们要打扮成瓦肯人，像史波克先生那样。
We're going to have to pin our ears and go after this thing.
我们得咬紧牙关，去对抗这个东西。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回归。
["THE SHARK FIGHTER!" BY THE AQUABATS!]
（《鲨鱼斗士！》-水族人乐队）